presque six ans après la catastrophe
la cicatrice est toujours là le chemin
de fer balafre encore le centre ville et
le train continue de sillonner dans lac
mégantic entre le statu quo et la
promesse d'une voie de contournement au
nord de la ville le choix est vite fait
pour les citoyens contourner permettrait
au moins de réduire les risques et
d'éloigner un peu le souvenir du
terrible désastre mais lorsque le tracé
présumé commence à faire son chemin
les premières inquiétudes s'affiche
entre autres parmi les agriculteurs
expropriés potentiel moi j'ai senti
angleterre et où ce qu'est la voie
ferrée va passer un commentaire environ
moitié dans chez les élus locaux qu'il a
et rci scindé en deux on vide poches
d'un dragon rider tard que chez les
citoyens
le pas dans ma cour et manifeste moi je
veux pas du tout ça tant chez nous
lorsque le tracé proposé devient en fait
le tracé accepté l'annoncé est alors
faite en grandes pompes par québec et
ottawa pour celle qui administrait la
ville au moment de la catastrophe
c'est un soulagement c'est une nouvelle
qui nous ré temps forts qui nous permet
à nouveau de regarder l'avenir lorsque
d'autres modifications sont encore
demandé par certains après l'annonce
sans surprise québec en a déjà scellé le
destin
quelques semaines auparavant il ya des
ajustements qui seront passées mais à la
marge
alors on peut recommencer à zéro le
train bientôt éloigné des commerces et
les résidences c'est une promesse longue
de près de 13 km au coût de 133 millions
de dollars qui deviendra réalité pour
si tout va bien ici frédéric arnould
radio canada montréal